Christopher's in Seattle hi Christopher
welcome today Ramsey show hey Dave hey
what's up here
you too my nothing I went to a few
earlier this year and we're about a
quarter of the way into baby sub-2 but
we're planning on getting married in
August of next year and I'm just trying
to figure out where on the budget
am I supposed to fit in the wedding
funds am I supposed to put it along with
the UH he hang off the debt or do I
prioritize that and then work on the
debt afterwards
yeah what are you planning on spending
on the wedding not a lot her family has
given us about four thousand and my
family's pitching in a little bit so
Kyle around 25 to 3,000 okay that's not
much all right so just take you know and
you're getting married in August so
that's eight months right yeah so let's
take three thousand dollars and had five
hundred dollars a month for the first
six months of the year to your budget
you know it just slows down your but
your debt snowball by $500 a month
right now you say you say $500 a month
January through June and you have $3,000
Josh don't chain like a packet like
really hard just do it while I'm doing
babies up to the wedding oh yeah you
have you have eight months right I mean
if you can do $500 a month towards it
you'll be fine now here's the other
thing okay weddings are like anything
else well they're not like anything else
but but as far as financially they're
like anything else this is a project and
so you have a timeline and you have a
budget and you have the categories
within the budget so if you say we're
going to spend three thousand thousand
dollars on the wedding
four thousand from her family three
thousand from you guys then you need to
know what you're going to pay for the
dress what you're going to pay for the
target photographer what you're going to
pay for the reception and you need to
break that out and in
to total no more than $7,000 because if
you don't think that motion gets
involved in this budget this is the most
emotional budget you'll ever do in your
life yeah it's already been famous no
yeah so you guys lay that out and then
actually there's some good percentages
out there one of the forms is in the
back of the smart money smart kids book
on weddings and there's good percentages
out there and you can do whatever you
want to do but the typical wedding has X
percent spend on the dress X percent
spent on the location X percent spent on
the reception afterwards which by the
way with the typical wedding is by far
the most expensive piece is the
reception typically it's more than yes
you've nothing that a couple of times
yeah more than half so I mean you could
do a potluck I'd save a lot but bottled
water and a potluck but it's up to you
what you want to do but the you guys but
the point is begin with the end in mind
so you lay out okay we're going with the
end in mind is August we have this
amount of money we need and we're going
to break it down but you can't just the
language you used when I asked you what
you were going to spend was kind of
wishy-washy it wasn't real solid lag see
the one who knows all the stuff about
the wedding no no that's not a number
that's not gonna work and it was about
2,000 yeah yeah no we need a number that
we both agree to and is a total and is a
part of a whole I mean as a whole and
then the dress is a part of a whole the
photography is part of all the
receptionist part of a whole the
honeymoon is part of a whole yes so on
because that way you plan in and you
have your wonderful day there's not
financial stress and if she's looking at
a dress that's twice as much as you
budgeted for then she automatically
knows that dress is not gonna happen
unless she cancels the photographer
right we've already paid off her dress
so that was actually a good you're
missing a point to class the point is
you need guidelines okay the point and
if you take zero for the dress because
it's already paid off that's okay but
have it all written out as to where the
it's like building a house okay it's
like running out right one of our big
live events that we run we know what the
we know what the labor costs to put the
lights up we know what the renting of
the venue costs we
what the drivers are gonna cost to get
the speakers to the event we know what
our hotel cost is gonna be you you line
out the cost when you're running a
project and you put it to the timeline
and you get stuff done on the timeline
and it there's just no stress then
people that stay stressed outs because
they don't have any guidelines they
don't have any any guardrails in their
life which gives you the ability to say
no to the most important person you can
never say no to which is yourself learn
to say no to yourself because you gave
yourself a guideline that gets us to our
overall goals please do that with a
budget it will keep her mother out of it